[Music]
the Avengers and game Super Bowl trailer
has just dropped and even though it
flies by in a brief 30 seconds there's
still a lot to unpack from it throughout
this video I'll be breaking down
everything that you need to know about
the trailer as well as giving my
thoughts on what could happen in the
film there are potentially a lot of
spoilers here so if you don't want to
know anything and then I highly suggest
that you turn off now but without the
way I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I watch it so you don't
have to the trailer opens with the world
desolated by the snap new york seems
like a lifeless landscape and it's clear
that the planet losing 3.5 billion
people in an instant has had a massive
effect on not only the world but the
survivors that have been left behind
this is further exemplified by the
poster at a Relief Center that asks
where do we go and now that they're gone
however this doesn't mean that the
Avengers are taking it lying down and it
just opposing the first trailer we got
there's very much a feeling that the
team are getting back on the horse and
taking the fight to Thanos one of the
most interesting aspects of the trailer
is that Tony and nebula now seem to be
working together to get themselves out
of the situation and I left them
stranded in space the first of my fan
theories is that they will get the ship
to a point that they are able to send
out a distress beacon to earth rocket
will be able to read this having worked
on the ship already and with help from
pepper in the leaked rescue suit they
will both go and get their Tony and
nebula will then be adrift in space
hoping that their signal got out and
that is why Tony leaves the message for
pepper as he knows she will eventually
get it it just may be too late
my second ban theory comes from Katie
Lee who often helps out on the show she
talks about Rockets role in the film as
well as the time-travel ass
in the original message that she sent me
she says every theory I have is based on
the logic of everything we've seen so
far part of me does think that it could
all be thrown out the window if they go
down the alternate multiverse route with
parallel timelines I'm trying to piece
together how they could do it but it's
very difficult like I think it's clear
that the reason characters such as the
ancient one and Ronan the accuser or
returning is because we will see the
quantum realm being used to gather the
Infinity stones for memorable scenes we
have already witnessed ie the battle for
New York
so rocket will go back to the final
scenes of guardians for the Power Stone
Stark and ant-man to the battle for New
York for Loki's mind Stone scepter cap
and widow gone back to get the tesseract
and that's why they left one of the
Guardians with the Avengers in the
penultimate scene of infinity war they
needed the surviving characters each to
have already come in contact or close to
an infinity stone for the quantum realm
gathering of the stones arc to come to
fruition to me this makes a lot of sense
and definitely seems quite possible the
Avengers clearly go back to New York to
get the mind and space stone and need
someone with knowledge of how the Power
Stone was first grabbed by the Guardians
Thor will likely go back to get the
reality stone and this is why we see him
in a location that looks far removed
from earth remember the Avengers only
need to get one Infinity stone to stop
the snap and obviously the team want to
spread themselves into as many moments
as possible and this gives them the best
chance of getting the stones and of
course love to hear your thoughts on the
trailer and if you agree with me make
sure you leave them in the comments
below and if you like this video then
please give it a thumbs up and check out
my recent breakdown of the new birds of
prey trailer which would be linked at
the end I'll leave a link to Katie's
Twitter in the description so make sure
you follow her if she drops fan theories
like this all the time this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you